moi je suis d'origine guadeloupéenne et
je suis né en france hexagonale et j'ai
entendu parler de louis delgrès ce
relativement tard dans ma vie et à un
moment où j'étais en plein
questionnement personnelle par rapport à
mon identité ma place dans ce vaste
monde
et bien cette figure et mes revenus la
figure de l'hôtel grèce et j'ai commencé
à faire des premiers sons de blues ayant
chanté en créole en pensant à lui on en
a tous un lien avec la guadeloupe dans
ce groupe parce que baptiste et de
nantes et donc historiquement il ya un
lien fort avec les antilles françaises
et moi j'ai un lien plus personnel sur
mes parents m'ont conçu en guadeloupe
oui ben moi je fais une antenne donc
effectivement tout tout ce port nantais
a eu un lien super fort et voilà
dramatique aussi avec les antilles
oui c'est un album qui est engagé mais
il n'est pas engagé que pour les
descendants d'esclaves pour les
guadeloupéens pour les martiniquais
puisque on se rend bien compte que
finalement la figure de louis delgrès ce
déjà elle même si quelqu'un qui était
métis vraiment quelqu'un de très très
moderne dans à la fois le personnage
mais aussi non dans sa démarche
et puis son idée de la liberté c'est une
idée qui contemporaine qui est encore
très importante et à défendre
aujourd'hui donc on se rend compte au
fur et à mesure qu'on joue qu on
rencontre les gens que ça va bien au
delà de juste une revendication pour une
petite île ou autre c'est quelque chose
dans lequel tout le monde se retrouve
c'est la liberté d'être qui on est
d'assumer toutes les parties mais de qui
on est non défense a vraiment tous les
jours dans nos concerts
il ya aussi un peu d'anglais et un peu
de français aussi par exemple survivre
sur la route on utilise le français
voient la danse est un mélange mais
effectivement il ya quand même quelque
chose d un enracinement dans la langue
créole et c'est ce qui fait l'unicité et
on est les seuls à faire ça on s'est
rendu compte de ça on est seul à
mélanger les choses de cette manière là
ce blues avec ce côté rock à la fois et
toujours en toile de fond des fois
d'aider des guitares un peu mandingue
l'afrique n'est jamais très loin mais
vraiment on est dans le temps dans le
bayou aussi dans le sud des états unis
donc oui et ça voyage au niveau tant au
niveau des langues que de la musique
simple iphone iphone os est moins fort
gestamp est pas encore
ou moins karpaty dit on priait points
[Musique]
ap